greetings greetings bill nighy here on
Facebook live in the Startalk studio and
I'm here with the remarkable and
insightful and hilarious and very nice
Chuck nice Oh Chuck nice hey Bill
well we're on Facebook log the world
could be watching if the world chose to
world could be watching if the world
chose to we have a topic today that you
want to discuss well you know before we
you know we're going to take some
questions as we all do whenever we do
Facebook live we take some questions
from the audience
making question but before we do got to
tell you about Startalk all-access of
course you know if you want to get
exclusive original content if you want
video versions of the actual podcast
that we do Startalk all-access is the
way to do it it is a subscription
service and we've got great stuff on
there this week we've got an extended
interview with Terry Crews a muscle guy
from Brooklyn nine-nine he and Emil did
an interview we also have from our
holiday party a meal kit which is where
Neal talks to people who how can I put
comment on his videos and they'd they
say all kinds of video about people
comment on the video yes it is very meta
message meta yeah let us modern
expression because uh but right now
because we're live it gives us an
opportunity to interact with you and if
you want to ask a question I mean
there's a bunch of people on here
already saying of course they're just
showing you all kinds of love I love you
bill and a look at this Heather comes
right out of the box can afford
divisional math assist in developing
time travel how about baby so we have
four dimensional math everybody
okay so there's Y and X and Z and then
there's time so x the fourth dimension
something you have an autopilot on a
modern plane for example you have to put
in not only where you want to go at what
altitude above sea level you have to
also put in what time you want to get
there you can't put down in any time as
a range of times that will permit as far
as time travel go
seems to me you'd have to take the
fourth dimension into account afar
there's no way to travel backwards in
time that anybody knows up now you can
travel forward in time we just did there
is there is a physics theory that you
could build a time machine that would
enable you to go back in time but you
can only go back to when the machine was
built and you have to travel at
relativistic speeds which would kill you
would tear you like a black hole you'd
be spaghettified catify and some trouble
all right now the answer simply as far
as I know is no there you go along with
this wishful thinking about time
machines I always remind people just try
to be in the moment this is the time
we're alive right now
embrace it there you go make the world a
better place take a chuck a so hey good
answer and I love this Glenn March it's
just as hey Bill which is more numerous
stars in the Milky Way or your
collection of Boca right now because of
my new and fabulous relationship with
Nick Graham the clothing designer I am
now kind of about 500 bowties really
about 200 billion stars in our galaxy so
also this is kind of what six in one
hand have yeah really yeah okay so uh
let's find somebody who well first of
all guys go I got to tell you people
just love you man it is amazing like a
bill bill and one says one person just
goes bill bill bill come on we love this
song exactly so hey Bill Frank Cain
wants to know this hi Bill what is the
best thing we can do as citizens to
promote the education of science and
hopefully teach the next generation that
the truth and facts are actual things
well that's really what you should do is
watch Star Trek all-access live that's
what you should do right am i right
people I love that and more every day so
yeah you should watch this podcast and
turn it up loud
you should everybody we have to
participate right now we have a
situation where
people are denying each other's points
of view we have to have a way of
communicating that involves a
partnership we're in this together we're
going to learn about climate change
together we're going to learn about the
role of finances and tax structures
together we're going to do this together
and this is a difficult time but I
propose that if we just get started the
longest journey starts with a single
step so hi everybody I hope you're
watching the show all of you there you
go
how about this one this guy just this
bill can you please ring the bell we
love that boom there you go ask answered
ok you asked you received here who God
did I miss this one I just won feeling
up the excitement excitement I'm losing
it excitement slipping away bring it
back now how how do you handle a flat
earther
oh you guys there's not that many flat
earther I don't think it's not a bigger
and it's not a real thing ok so are you
looking for people who are desperately
in need of attention in medieval text
you find references to round earth there
hasn't been a real Flat Earth person in
a long time and you guys we have
pictures from space if you're not happy
with that you want to go on a cruise you
get over the horizon you can't see land
anymore why is that try it yourself
don't take my word for it there you go
time there's a lunar eclipse look for
the earth shadow on the moon
Jess Woods wants to know how do we push
back against this age of science deniers
especially from on a political how do we
do it with star talk live that's how we
do it
sure I know with the longest journey
starts with a single step so we're doing
this kind of show to raise awareness
that science I claim is the best idea
people have ever had we work very hard
to find a justifiable true belief to
learn things about nature the atomic
number of rubidium is 37 and that's just
how it is
it's very little evidence that it's any
other number so we embrace that and we
move forward along this line we look at
the neutrons in ice and we count we look
at the bub
the snowflakes between the tines and
ancient ice and we figured out the books
getting warmer faster than ever in human
history so we got to do something about
it Chuck
there you go so Jim far up with a pee in
front of Exile it's not far
I guess it's Jim far hey Bill any idea
how we can teach critical thinking to
the youth of America
uh we get critical thinking as a I don't
say the curriculum but well it is in
science class we wanted to have critical
critical thinking being embraced and
just everybody roughly critical thinking
involves at least three things you have
to start with a claim the claim has to
have a way that it could be shown to be
false in the case of the if I say the
earth is round and you say the earth
isn't round you have to we have to agree
on a method by which we could show that
the earth is not round but then within
that one example every time you try to
do that you find out the herbs really
Israel and then you have to respect
authority you have to agree on somebody
that's an authority if I claim the
atomic number of rubidium 37 we have to
agree on a way to prove that was I guess
a mass spectrometer and we could of
course read scientific papers so and
then and then I just always ask you the
simplest explanation is generally the
best hypothesis and a scientific
explanation should have all the features
and parts it needs but no more the same
with environmental regulations should
have all the regulations we need no more
no more but all the ones we need he'll
you once you need and so what would the
problem we got right now Chuck yes yes
is people are doubling down on their
denial and this is apparently a result
of a phenomenon they called the backfire
effect I'm not trying to introduce a
term to explain the phenomenon but when
people are in denial about evidence they
and they're confronted with new evidence
that conflicts with their belief or
worldview they double down as human
nature you double down on your denial so
right now we're in a phase where people
who are very influential in the world's
know
important world's largest most
influential government are in denial
about climate change so we got to work
together in a partnership to show that
there's a way to know that the earth is
getting warmer because of humans and
then we can all work together to resolve
what do you say come on everybody it'll
be fun
how could you deny an appeal such as
that amazing all right um love you bill
so glad you're outspoken that wasn't for
me even though I love you I am outspoken
that was Johnny in here I was Johnny out
hahaha okay these a lot of you guys are
kind of giving us the same questions so
if your jaw you're a filter - I am the
filter of glass weary filter who shall
not bad okay I don't know what that was
you just you're angry today Chuck you've
had anger had a lot of anger today okay
yes you got three kids you know what
that about the future it says it all
that says it all
let's see here I'm a oh hey this is Oh
God
rah Raja and NIM near mal Raja hey Bill
I'm a museum educator and I talk to kids
about a lot of things from dinosaurs to
galaxies what do you think that every
single kid and the general public should
know about science oh well the big thing
we want you to get a student of any age
is that science is a process it's a way
we know the world we have thought about
this for centuries and humans have come
up with this idea that you observe a
phenomenon in nature that you find
remarkable you'll notice my eyebrows
went up as a representation and then you
come up with an idea in your head that
you would think would explain this we
call a hypothesis and this is the idea
below hypothesis okay so then you come
up with a test to see if your hypothesis
might be true and then you run a test
and you compare what happened to what
you thought would happen and then you
glove with another hypothesis you
continually revise it working our way to
truth to the justifiable true belief to
the
so something that you are pretty sure
has got to be true Tomic number of
strontium is 38 for example and so this
process is we want everybody to embrace
and if you want to look around we are on
electric computer machines and all this
is a result of the process of science
humans have understood the four
fundamental forces in nature that we
know of so far and we've created this
technology that is based on our
understanding of nature and we eat food
grown on farms based on our
understanding of nature and natural
processes and we communicate around the
world because we learn to navigate on
this big ball and we know that it's a
ball because we've had a high pub where
you come up with hypotheses we run tests
and we compare what happened to what we
thought we have that's the main thing
science rules there you have it well hey
listen thanks for all the love you guys
are showing us on Facebook live - Chris
and Zachary and Jared and Burton and Jim
and joy and Christian and Tina and
Dakota we're not going to get to you
guys we'll just want to say hi and with
you and we love you and thank you and
make sure that you go to start off all
access com subscribe a to our service
that gives you original exclusive
content as well as everything that we do
commercial free and until next time bill
turn it up loud thanks for watching
everybody